la séance est reprise à l'ordre du jour
appelle des explications de vote des
groupes et le vote par scrutin public
sur la proposition de loi adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale créant de nouveaux
droits en faveur des malades les
personnes en fin de vie
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
avant de passer au vote je vais donner
la parole à ceux de nos collègues qui
ont été inscrits par les groupes pour
expliquer leur vote
j'indique au sénat que la conférence des
présidents a fixé à raison d'un orateur
par groupe à 7 minutes le temps attribué
à chaque groupe politique
les sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
aucun groupe disposant de trois minutes
je vous inviterai ensuite à vous rendre
la salle des conférences pour voter je
suspendrai la séance pendant la durée du
scrutin qui est prévu pour une demi
heure je proclame n'est enfin le
résultat à l'issue du dépouillement
aux alentours de 17h45 puis je donnerai
la parole au gouvernement donc la parole
et est d'abord à notre collègue
françoise gatel pour le groupe u10 union
centriste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous avons
démocratiquement et longuement débattu
d'un texte important traitant de la fin
de vie ce texte proposait deux
évolutions par rapport à la loi leonetti
de 2005
la première la sédation profonde et
continue pour des personnes atteintes
d'une maladie incurable réfractaires à
tout traitement et dont le pronostic
vital est engagé
le caractère contraignant des directives
anticipées
le texte proposé par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat était un
texte équilibré et mesuré qui permettait
de répondre aussi bien la demande
légitime d'une fin de vie apaisée qu'aux
besoins de sécurisation des médecins
sans pour autant banaliser les actes
pouvant conduire à la mort le sénat a
également de manière pertinente mis en
évidence l'indignité la grande misère
des soins palliatifs dans notre pays
aujourd'hui accessible à seulement 20%
des personnes qui en auraient besoin
le sénat a aussi enrichi le texte en
insistant sur le développement des soins
palliatifs sur l'ensemble du territoire
non seulement à l'hôpital mais aussi
dans les structures médico sociales et à
domicile aujourd'hui 70% des français
meurent à l'hôpital alors que 70% des
français voudrait mourir chez eux
il a également plaidé pour une meilleure
formation soin palliatif des médecins
mais surtout ce texte affirme un devoir
de fraternité envers les plus
vulnérables d'entre nous ceux qui vont
mourir il affirmait par là même la
double finalité de la médecine tout à la
fois curatif et palliatifs
mais au cours de son examen en séance ce
texte est devenu une coquille vide
la sédation profonde telle que définie
acte de compassion et de bienveillance
n'est pas le cheval de troie d'une
euthanasie déguisé le sénat a clairement
refusé le droit au suicide assisté à
l'euthanasie des questions qui en effet
ne saurait être débattu au simple détour
d'un amendement sur un texte qui ne
concerne encore une fois que ceux qui
mourir et non ceux qui veulent mourir
nos débats ont été nourris de nos
convictions de nos expériences
personnelles de nos émotions de nos
valeurs mais aussi de nos
questionnements wolton leur mort à ceux
qui n'ont plus que quelques moments à
vivre
wolton des moments de vie de partager
des changes avec les proches quand la
science est devenue impuissante à
soulagés que l'heure de la mort a sonné
portons atteinte à la vie en accordant
dans les derniers moments le repos qui
apaise allège les souffrances et les
tourments mais de quoi parlons nous nous
parlons ici des derniers jours d'être
dernières heures des derniers instants
de personnes en situation de souffrance
extrême qu aucun traitement ne peut
soulager
peut-on légitimement refusé à des
personnes qui ont clairement exprimé
leur volonté
le droit d'être endormi pour apaiser
leur souffrance lors de leurs derniers
moments
peut-on décemment les fermes et de ce1
seul endosser la responsabilité d'un
acte de sédation qu'il accepterait par
humanité sans que la loi ne le protège
car c'est bien ce que proposait le texte
que nous votons aujourd'hui la politique
un devoir d'exigence de vérité et où il
faut ici dire encore aujourd'hui des
hommes en souffrance on angoisse et dans
une grande solitude
abandonné par une science devenue
impuissante livré à la conscience et à
l'humanité d'une équipe médicale que nul
ne protège derrière nos débats derrière
nos mots il ya des sommes confrontés à
l'une qui moment de leur vie et le
désarroi de l'impuissance des familles
avec le président de la commission des
affaires sociales les rapporteurs ont
accompli un travail de grande qualité
empreint de rigueur et d'humanité ils
ont pesé chaque mot clarifier chaque
principe en prenant soin d'ôter de ce
texte les scories qui pouvait provoquer
les consciences ils ont clairement est
strictement défini les conditions
d'encadrement du droit à la sédation
profonde et continue et du renforcement
des directives anticipées
ce texte était à la fois trop pour
certains
pas assez pour d'autres mais aujourd'hui
il n'est rien il est un oubli d'humanité
et un défaut de fraternité aussi
aussi en mon âme et conscience avec
grand regret et anciennement très
sincèrement nouveau le travail des
rapporteurs et du président de la
commission des affaires sociales je
voterai contre ce texte
car ce n'est pas ainsi que les hommes va
forcément mourir
la parole
et quand madame catherine de roche pour
le groupe l'est républicain devait la
parole monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues débattre de la fin de
vie est toujours très sensible
nous devons légiférer nous déterminer
sur cette question délicate et
douloureuse
alors qu inévitablement nous projetons
de fait la mort de ceux que nous aimons
et notre propre mort là aussi nos
croyances nos angoisses
depuis trois ans plusieurs rapports ont
été rendus sur le sujet celui du
professeur six cas l'avis du comité
consultatif national d'éthique et un
colloque a été organisé dans nos murs en
février dernier la proposition de loi no
collègue député léonetti claisse
s'inscrit dans la continuité des lois
adoptées ces quinze dernières années la
loi de 1999 qui a garantit l'accès aux
soins palliatifs celle de 2002 qui est
accordée aux malades la possibilité de
refuser un traitement lui paraissant
trop insupportable et la loi de 2005 qui
a offert aux malades la possibilité de
demander aux médecins de suspendre ou de
ne pas entreprendre des traitements
jugés comme une obstination
déraisonnable à l'initiative du
rapporteur michel amiel et gérard dériot
dont je tiens à saluer l'excellent
travail
la commission des affaires sociales du
sénat avait souhaité clarifier ou
modifier le texte issu de l'assemblée
nationale et limiter le caractère
automatique des décisions concernant la
fin de vie ainsi concernant le refus de
l'obstination déraisonnable
la commission a défini les obligations
minimales qui s'attache à la mise en à
la mise en oeuvre de la procédure
collégiale pour les conditions de mise
en oeuvre la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès la commission a
supprimé la mention de prolongation
inutile de la vie jugé source
d'ambiguïté et celle de l'hydratation ou
de l'alimentation artificielle afin de
soutenir à la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état
elle a précisé que dans le cas où une
personne souhaite arrêter tout
traitement engageant ainsi son pronostic
vital à court terme
la sédation profonde et continue
la mise en oeuvre qu'en cas de
souffrance réfractaires cette nouvelle
rédaction de la commission visait à
écarter toute dérive vers le suicide
assisté
néanmoins le texte de la commission a
été largement remanié lors de son examen
en séance à la clique le premier en
matière de soins palliatifs
il est désormais précisé que les soins
palliatifs doivent être mis en oeuvre
sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est ainsi que les professionnels de
santé devront mettre en oeuvre tous les
moyens à leur disposition pour assurer à
toute personne une fin de vie digne et
accompagné du meilleur apaisement
possible de la souffrance ces moyens
consistent en particulier dans des
unités de soins palliatifs équitablement
réparties sur le territoire national et
le développement du nombre de lits dans
les services hospitaliers et des unités
mobiles destinés à oeuvrer dans les cas
d'hospitalisation à domicile ou dans les
établissements médico sociaux
l'accent a également été mis sur la
formation des professionnels de santé et
des personnels des ehpad l'inégalité
territoriale des soins palliatifs est un
constat partagé sur tous les bancs et
que le sénat en soient inquiets n'est
pas illogique à l'article de la notion
d'inutilité des traitements et remplacer
par la notion d'inefficacité la
commission des lois est à cet égard je
remercie notre collègue françois pilet
pour l'ensemble de ces amendements a
proposé que le recours à la procédure
collégiale soit limitée au seul cas où
le patient est hors d'état d'exprimer sa
volonté
enfin il a été définie que l'hydratation
artificielle est un soin et non un
traitement qui peut être maintenue
jusqu'en fin de vie pour ce qui est de
la sédation profonde et continue
l'article 3 qui prévoyait sa mise en
oeuvre pour les patients dont le
pronostic vital engagé à court terme a
été modifié en séance le caractère
continu jusqu'au décès de la sédation a
été supprimé seul reste la notion de
sédation profonde 7 sédation devant
s'accompagner l'arrêt de tous les
traitements maintient en vie la
commission des lois a précisé que cette
décision d'arrêt d'être
comment devait revenir aux patients la
commission allait supprimer le bilan du
développement des soins palliatifs celui
ci a été réintroduit en séance quant à
l'opposé habilités des directives
anticipées prévues à l'article 8
plusieurs amendement est adopté il
prévoit que ces directives anticipées ne
doivent pas contrevenir à la liberté de
prescription du médecin et ne lui sont
plus opposable
elles peuvent être révisées et révoquer
à tout moment par tous moyens en cas
d'inscription des directives dans le
registre national à rappels réguliers
leur existence sera effectué à leurs
auteurs le médecin traitant pour
informer ses patients à leur demande des
conditions de rédaction des directives
anticipées
les personnes placées sous tutelle
pourront rédiger des directives dans les
conditions du droit commun enfin
l'article 9 précise le statut du
témoignage de la personne de confiance
le texte ainsi sud nos débats notre
collègue françoise gatel a dit est en
effet différent du texte initial mais
ceci prouve surtout combien réouvrir la
loi consensuelle leonetti de 2005 pour
satisfaire un engagement du président de
la république il faut le rappeler a
renvoyé chaque sénateur à ses
convictions profondes sur la fin de vie
comment pouvait-il en être autrement
celle-ci ce partisan d'une hta nazis
active du suicide assisté sont peu
nombreux dans notre groupe
plus nombreux sont les sénateurs qui
préférerait sans doute un nouveau texte
sur ce sujet difficile
un vrai développement des soins
palliatifs assurant ainsi l'application
effective de la loi 2005 en commission
des affaires sociales comme celle des
lois le travail soigné de nos rapporteur
pour améliorer le texte de l'assemblée
nationale n'a pas suffi à apaiser leurs
craintes d'une dérive l'euthanasie qu
personne n'est à blâmer il n'y a ni
conservatisme d'un côté ni progrès de
l'autre
d'autant que la notion de progrès en
matière de lois sociétale est toujours
très complexe mais il existe des
positions différentes toutes mes risques
méritant reste la mutuelle humilité une
deuxième lecture va suivre je souhaite
que l'assemblée nationale ne se contente
pas comme c'est souvent la règle de
revenir à son propre texte en faisant fi
des doutes émis par notre haute
assemblée les termes de continuité la
sédation jusqu'au décès et de droit
opposable à la mort doivent être mûres
définies dans les mots ont du sens et
doivent être posées le débat a montré
par ailleurs que la perception des
termes employés étaient très différentes
selon que l'on est ou non familier du
monde médical et l'environnement des
personnes malades en fin de vie
ne l'oublions pas un deuxième lecture
pour conclure notre groupe avait laissé
à chacun de ses membres une totale
liberté de vote tout au long de l'examen
du texte il en est bien évidemment de
même pour le vote final
merci ma chère collègue madame la
ministre
chers collègues au nom de tous je
voudrais souhaiter la plus cordiale
bienvenue
notre nouvelle collègue marie mercier
devenu sénateur de saône et loire en ce
moment je voudrais avoir une pensée
amicale pour notre ami jean patrick
courtois qui a été vice président de
notre assemblée ainsi que pour tous nos
collègues qui ont dû abandonner leur
mandat de sénateur par décision du
conseil constitutionnel de 11 juin
dernier
je voudrais appeler monsieur georges
labazée
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues sur un texte d'une telle
nature
la consigne de vote des groupes et bien
souvent il y en a pas oui mes chers
collègues comment peut-on demander un
groupe de voter comme selon nous une
seule femme sur des dispositions qui
font appel aux convictions les plus
personnels les plus intimes sur la
proposition de loi qui nous a été
présentée telle qu'adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale
il y avait ce qui était satisfait par le
texte en l'état
et puis il y avait ceux qui voulaient
aller plus loin difficile donc de
trouver une position commune
malgré tout une chose est évidente
personne ne souhaitait revenir en
arrière
c'était sans compter sur le sabotage de
l'article 3 et de l'article 8 dispositif
clé de ce texte
oui les chats collègues en supprimant le
droit à la sédation continue jusqu'au
décès je cite l'amendement puis en
supplément le droit pour chacun de voir
ces directives anticipées reconnu et
respecté la droite sénatoriale tout au
moins une partie de celle etc a montré
un visage suppose à pèse mes mots mes
erreurs enfin une partie
voilà un visage de réactions faisant
ainsi preuve
d'un terrible
d'intérim comportement et c'est qu'une
grande majorité de alors qu'une grande
majorité de français réclament des
avancées sur ce sujet elle a choisi de
dégrader sensiblement le droit existant
l'article 3 a donc été vidé de son sens
par l'amendement 59 terre de monsieur
dominique de legge et de ses collègues
qui a supprimé le caractère continu
jusqu'au décès de la sédation quel
dommage et jeune j'écoutais de ross et
quelques instants d'avoir succombé pour
certains aux fantasmes de la dérive
tomasik car ce n'était pas l'objet de
cette disposition et je tiens à saluer
madame la ministre monsieur le président
de la commission messieurs les
rapporteurs qui tout au long du débat
avec beaucoup de courage avait apporté
les explications les précisions à tous
les instants de notre discussion sur cet
article
il s'agissait non pas d'appliquer la
sédation pour le décès mais de
l'appliquer jusqu'au décès sacrée
différence vous en conviendrez
c'est un titre trois traits l'obligation
juridique de répondre à deux personnes
qui souhaitent que sa souffrance vote
les et je veux rappeler même les propos
de michel amiel rappelant disons une
recommandation de la société française
d'accompagnement et de soins palliatifs
qui disait la plupart des auteurs
réserve la mise en oeuvre d'une sédation
profonde maintenu jusqu'au décès aux
patients dont la mort est attendu dans
un bref délai généralement de quelques
heures à quelques jours
la sédation profonde et continuer dans
un acte thérapeutique qui fait appel à
l'arsenal des soins palliatifs pas de
rupture alors et tout le monde s'était
mis d'accord que sur le fait que le
patient a le droit dans des conditions
particulières de demander à une équipe
médicale
de bénéficier d'une sédation jusqu'au
moment de sa mort apporter des solutions
concrètes créé l'obligation juridique de
répondre à la souffrance d'une personne
qui va inéluctablement mourir voilà ce
qui nous anime
voilà ce que vous avez supprimé et nous
porterons une grande attention aux
comptes rendus des auditions à venir à
l'assemblée nationale lorsque les
députés questionneront les médecins
spécialistes et leur demande de rome
comment ils pourront appliquer la
sédation profonde non continue à une
personne qui souffre physiquement et
moralement
sans porter atteinte à la déontologie
médicale et comme cela ne suffisait pas
l'article 8 a également fait l'objet de
grandes modifications
l'amendement 67 de monsieur de lège et
autres sénateurs a supprimé le droit
opposable des directives anticipées
précisant que le médecin prend en compte
les vielles rétif anticipé mais que
celle-ci ne s'impose pas à lui vous
l'avez précisé lors de la présentation
de votre amendement chers collègues
cela renvoie une différence majeure
entre nous sur la question de savoir si
la proposition de loi doit ou non créer
un droit opposable alors plusieurs
critiques bien sûr nous ont été
adressées sur les textes alors disais
tantôt il s'agit d'un texte qui protège
le médecin par le patient
c'est une proposition de loi pour les
médecins papoul est passé à bien voilà
aujourd'hui vous donner désormais un
crédit qui n'étaient pas nécessaires à
ces allégations l'article 8 étant vidé
de sa substance l'esprit de cette loi
est définitivement contourner je
regrette d'ailleurs que l'amendement
présenté par dominique gillot est signée
par le groupe socialiste et républicain
sur l'information des directives
anticipées lors de la journée défense et
citoyenneté n'ait pas été adoptée malgré
l'avis favorable du
gouvernement triste constat qui est le
nôtre en ce milieu d'après-midi à
l'article big vous demander de voter des
dispositions qui permettraient à toute
personne majeure de rédiger des
directives anticipées pour le cas où il
serait un jour hors d'état d'exprimer sa
volonté mais sans garantie pour cette
personne que ces directives saute un
jour appliquée par le médecin sans
compter l'absence d'un dispositif qui
permettrait une formation réelle et
complète de l'existence de ce droit de
la nécessité de rédiger de telles
directives texte pour le moins bizarre
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs me supplier
dans vos interventions
je suis surpris que cette version qui
nous est aujourd'hui soumise et qui ne
tient en aucun cas content d accord
trans partisan qui ont été passées à
l'assemblée nationale je vous renvoie au
texte tel qu'il avait été adopté très
largement à l'assemblée nationale par
delà des aspects partisans je suis
attristé par cette disposition adoptée
alors que les travaux de la commission
affaires sociales et les lois ont
consisté à chaque étape de la
proposition à claques compenser le
président avancé même si nous l'avons
pas été d'accord sur tout et je salue et
je rappelle je salue les travaux des
rapporteurs amiel et des rios et je
salue le courage de notre président je
veux saluer je termine là dessus les
membres du groupe communiste et
républicain le groupe écologiste le rdse
dans sa grande majorité
ainsi qu'une partie du groupe centriste
et même quelques républicains
progressistes étrange retour en arrière
que ce texte qui nous est soumis en vie
dans ce texte la substance un petit faut
conclure la la c'est bien
mais j'ai le progrès de l'ex ump vous
avez souhaité calquer le modèle
américain vous de t'inspirer de tea
party vous avez suivi le talent de la
manif pour tous
je vous propose une nouvelle appellation
vous deviez donner des conservateurs
mais un merci la parole est à madame
corinne bouchoux pour le groupe
écologiste
vous avez la parole
l'équipe hockey
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
allez-y monsieur le président madame la
ministre
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues sénatrices et sénateurs
je voudrais dans un premier temps
remercié les rapporteurs amiel desriaux
notre collègue pillet le président de la
commission des affaires sociales alain
milon et tous les collègues de la
commission des affaires sociales dont
nous ne partagions pas tout à fait les
vues mais dont nous souhaitons salué le
travail rigoureux équilibré et on dire à
posteriori
malheureusement visionnaire comme cela a
été dit dans les interventions
précédentes le premier scandale en
france c'est l'inégalité face à la mort
les soins palliatifs sont trop peu
nombreux et à cet égard les chèques ou
la non-application de la loi leonetti
ont été dénoncées à diverses reprises
aussi nous saluons les progrès dans le
nouveau texte concernant les soins
palliatifs et la mesure des inégalités
sur le territoire une préoccupation
majeure
nous l'avons déjà dit lors de
précédentes interventions 79 sénatrices
et sénateurs de toutes les familles
politiques souhaitait aller plus loin
que le texte initial
un débat de qualité a permis dans la
nuit de mardi à mercredi de considérer
que nous étions encore trop peu nombreux
puisque 75 personnes ont voté pour ces
amendements qui permettait de suivre la
volonté des personnes qui ne souhaitait
plus souffrir lors ce qu'ils étaient
atteints de maladies incurables
nous aurions voulu plus mais je voulais
vous mes chers collègues pas un instant
nous n'avions anticiper ce qui allait se
produire mercredi à savoir un
détricotage pas à pas méticuleux au
début masqué et ensuite - où l'on a et
c'est très difficile à expliquer en
dehors de cette assemblée réussi à
inventer la sédation profonde et
intermittente puisque nous avons décidé
que la sédation profonde ne serait plus
continue jusqu'à la mort je ne suis pas
sûr que les collègues il a été voté
majoritairement pour ce point je ne suis
pas sûr que tous les collègues et celle
excuses que je verrai réaliser la
monstruosité de ce que nous avons voté
toutes les personnes qui ont accompagné
des personnes en fin de vie vous le
diront ensuite
ensuite concernant les directives un
deuxième tour de passe passe a permis en
quelque sorte de rendre ces directives
optionnel face au pouvoir médical ce qui
était justement l' inverse de ce qu
avait défendu la commission des affaires
sociales est ce qu avait rappelé madame
la ministre nous en arrivons donc
mercredi un texte qui est vidé de deux
de ses éléments essentiels l'article 3
nous avons fait voter les absents
l'article 3 a été validé à l'aide d'un
scrutin public dont certains doivent
amèrement regretter que l'on ait pu
voter pour eux et nous arrivons donc un
texte qui est devenu inepte à savoir que
non seulement nous n'avons pas créé de
nouveaux droits en faveur des malades et
des personnes en fin de vie mais nous
avons réussi mes chers collègues a
reculé par rapport à ce qui était la loi
léonetti ça peut être été un petit peu
masquées dans la presse
ces deux modalités ont dévitalisées
totalement ce texte de loi de sa portée
juridique et madame la ministre dont je
salue totalement le travail et la
loyauté même si nous n'avons pas eu les
mêmes positions
elle a défendu pas par un équilibre
politique avait tout son sens et par la
volonté on verra tout à l'heure de
combien mais de quelques-uns c'est non
seulement la loi sur la fin de vie qui a
été malmené mais c'est aussi toute
l'image du sénat qui a été corner qui
jusqu'à peu était le défenseur des
libertés individuelles et collectives
j'ai rendu compte
poursuivez
je pense que à partir du moment où on
n'avance pas on recule et en sciences
politiques
quand on est plus dans la conservation
mais que l'on revient sur des d'oise 3 à
qui ça s'appelle de la réaction pure et
simple
nous avons donc à mais je vois bien les
mines consterné de certains collègues
sur le côté droit de l'hémicycle
c'est simpliste mais c'est vrai y'a que
la vérité qui blesse vous êtes vexés
d'avoir laissé détricoter une loi comme
ça
il vous plait
ah non mais excusez moi là c'est
pathétique c'est mauvais pour suivre
on a des
s'il vous plaît nous s'il vous plaît
poursuivez merci monsieur le président
nous avons des malades qui nous
regardent nous avons des familles qui
nous regarde et je peux vous dire que
l'image qu'a donnée le sénat mercredi
n'était pas l'image d'un sénat
respectueux des équilibres politiques
parce que je suis désolé même si
majoritairement groupes écologistes nous
ne partagions pas la prudence du texte
initial le texte initial qu'on nous a
amenés ici ils étaient équilibrées
politiquement il était juste il était
censé il était respectueux des malades
il était respectueux des valeurs de la
république
mes chers collègues je ne réponds pas je
ne répondrai pas à ses aboiements qui ne
sont pas dignes d'un sujet de ce type et
genre doit restaurer la ccir colère la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
annie david
pour le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen je mangerai à chacun d'écouter
allez dit
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues comme je l'avais
indiqué en ouverture de l'examen de
cette proposition de loi le sujet de la
fin de vie est un sujet sensible
difficile à aborder
il renvoie pour chacune et chacun
d'entre nous a des moments douloureux
moments durant lesquels nous avons pu
être contraint de prendre des décisions
difficiles sur la fin de vie de nos
proches la plupart de nos concitoyennes
et de nos concitoyens comme nous a été
confronté à cette question difficile de
la fin de vie c'est certainement pour
cette raison que ce sujet mobilise
fortement et que les attentes citoyennes
sont importantes le concitoyennes nos
concitoyens veulent notamment que le
débat sortent des hôpitaux et du cadre
médical
ils et elles refusent que d'autres
jugent tout médecin décide à leur place
de la manière dont devra se dérouler
leur fin de vie et du moment où leur
souffrance seront abrégé enfin ils et
elles acceptent de moins en moins de ne
pouvoir accompagner convenablement leurs
proches dans leurs derniers instants
nous avions le devoir en tant que
parlementaire de les écouter d'entendre
leur besoin d'être acteurs actrices de
leur propre mort de leur garantir la
possibilité d'avoir une fin de vie qu'il
juge dignes pour eux mêmes sans
souffrance apaisé de leur permettre de
tenir la main de leurs proches quand la
mort approche nous devions sortir d'une
approche technicisé et médical de la
mort gelé dit nous devions sortir de
l'hôpital nous devions proposer des
solutions pour mieux mourir chez soi
entouré des siens sans avoir à attendre
que les souffrances deviennent
insupportables pourtant alors que notre
haute assemblée est réputé pour sa
sagesse pour les débats sur ce texte
n'ont été ni à la hauteur de cette
réputation ni à la hauteur du sujet
et ni surtout à la hauteur des attentes
de nos concitoyennes et de nos
concitoyens je ne m'attarderai pas sur
la forme ni sur les propos caricaturaux
qui ont pu être tenus sans resterait au
fond sur le fond donc une partie de la
droite sénatoriale s'est obstiné à
revenir sur des droits acquis si bien
que le nouveau titre de la proposition
de loi création de nouveaux droits pour
les personnes malades en fin de vie n'a
lui même plus de sens
la proposition de loi qui nous avait été
présenté avait pourtant une porte est
déjà limité il s'agissait davantage de
renforcer l'application de la loi
léonetti que de garantir de nouveaux
droits
ce que certains certaines dont je fais
partie on peut regretter
en effet nos concitoyennes concitoyens
étaient en attente d'une loi sincère et
claire sur la fin de vie qui permettrait
notamment l'ouverture d'un droit
vraiment nouveau celui de l'assistance
médicalisée pour mourir et le débat que
nous avons eu ici même le mercredi dans
la nuit a été d'une très haute tenue et
d'un très bon niveau 75 sénateurs et
sénatrices se sont exprimés en sa faveur
cela veut bien dire qu'il y a nécessité
à revenir sur ce dossier et que notre
assemblée n'est pas prête pour aller
plus loin pour autant et malgré ses
limites ce texte présentait deux
avancées notables
la première était la possibilité de
recourir à une sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès dans des cas
strictement définis quand le pronostic
vital est engagé à court terme en cas de
souffrance réfractaires à tout
traitement et ce bien sûr
conformément à la volonté du patient la
deuxième avant c était le renforcement
de la portée des directives anticipées
avec des mesures pour les rendre plus
utiliser plus exploitable et surtout
contraignantes
l'idée étant que les directives et ainsi
la volonté du patient doivent s'imposer
aux médecins le texte qui est soumis à
notre vote aujourd'hui
est un recul fort et devient et revient
même sur la loi leonetti d'abord
concernant la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès la droite une
partie en tout cas de la droite a adopté
un amendement qui supprime les termes
continue jusqu'au décès ce n'est ni plus
ni moins qu'un retour à l'existant la
sédation pouvait déjà être mises en
oeuvre comme une procédure de soins
palliatifs
or le fait qu'elle ne soit pas continue
obligé à réveiller la personne pour
qu'elle réitère son choix en l'état la
proposition de loi ne clarifient donc
rien en rien le droit actuel ni la porte
de nouveaux droits aux patients en fin
de vie de plus dès lors le sénat laisse
la possibilité d'arrêter la nutrition en
maintenant toutefois d'hydratation
la position est hypocrite l'issue est
bien la mort mais une mort lente
une mort de faim ensuite concernant les
directives anticipées la commission des
affaires sociales avait déjà relativisé
leur caractère contraignant
le médecin pouvait ne pas les appliquer
si la situation médicale qu'elle
décrivait n'était pas la même que la
situation médicale vécue par le patient
ceci afin de prendre en considération
les inquiétudes qui s'exprimait sur des
dérives possibles cela malheureusement
n'a pas été suffisant puisque en séance
publique le caractère contraignant a été
purement et simplement supprimé
désormais le médecin prend en compte des
directives
elle ne s'impose plus à lui quant à
l'obligation pour le médecin d'informer
le patient sur la possibilité de rédiger
des directives anticipées le médecin
sera tenu de le faire à la demande du
patient
le patient devra donc demandé à être
informé d'une possibilité qui lui est
offerte cette annonce ans le texte
notamment suite aux changements qui ont
eu lieu au sénat renforcent cependant
les demandes du législateur sujet des
soins palliatifs couverture demandé sur
l'ensemble du territoire et en dehors de
l'hôpital obligation de formation aux
soins palliatifs pour le personnel des
ehpad
demandes de rapports et de bilan sur la
formation des professionnels de santé
aux soins palliatifs ou plus globalement
sur le développement des soins
palliatifs
ces évolutions vont dans le bon sens
mais on sent limitée par le fait
qu'elles émanent du législateur qui est
contraint par l'article 40
en effet ce dans les soins palliatifs
ont besoin ce sont deux moyens
financiers or seul le gouvernement est à
même d'engager ses moyens et de faire du
développement de l'offre de soins
palliatifs une de ses priorités dans la
tente le législateur devra se contenter
de son rôle de contrôle et d'évaluation
si tant est que les rapports demandés
lui soit transmis ainsi cette avancée
sur les soins palliatifs est loin de
compenser les carences du texte tel
qu'il nous est présenté suite à l'examen
en séance publique au sénat aussi alors
qu'il comptait voter pour le texte
initial malgré les réserves que j'ai
émises dans mon intervention général le
groupe communiste républicain et citoyen
va te raconte la présente proposition de
loi leur collègue
la parole est au président jacques
mézard pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social et européen
et la parole monsieur le président
monsieur le président madame la ministre
est cher collègue dans la mémoire de
notre collègue henri caillavet
le groupe du rds eux à l'exception de
notre excellent collègue gilbert barbier
notre groupe votera contre ce texte
mais nous considérons qu'en la matière
comme en bien d'autres toutes les
expressions toutes les opinions sont
profondément respectable certains
certains et nous les avons souvent
combattu cris laissez les vivre d'autres
crient laisser nos mourir
le professeur richard zandberg écrit la
souffrance est hideuse et puisque les
moyens existent de l'apaiser il faut en
user sans hésiter c'est là tout l'enjeu
du débat qui touche par définition
chacune et chacun d'entre nous puisqu'il
participe de l'essence même de la vie
quitter la vie est inéluctable l'a
quitté dans la sérénité est un autre
enjeu c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
la grande majorité des sénatrices et des
sénateurs de notre groupe nous
regrettons que le texte ne soit pas
allée plus loin et qu'il n'est pas pris
en compte la volonté clairement exprimée
de nombreux malades à pouvoir bénéficier
de l'assistance médicalisée à mourir
madame la ministre au cours des débats
vous avez dit que le président de la
république était allé aussi loin que le
père mais l'état de la société française
que les débats publics les concertations
le rapport du cce avait abouti à un
consensus sur ce que contient le texte
et que l'engagement présidentiel était
respecté nous n'en sommes pas sûrs tout
en reconnaissant les avancées réalisées
autour d'un certain consensus
pourtant si difficile à atteindre dans
un domaine où l'idéologie n'a pas sa
place et le respect de chaque personne
doit avoir toute sa place
selon les sondages une grande majorité
de français se déclare en faveur de
l'euthanasie
il est vrai que la plupart des personnes
qui ont fait l'objet de ces sondages
sont en bonne santé et que lorsque le
terme approche les opinions peuvent
changer
le rapporteur l'a rappelé la semaine
dernière et je peux entendre cet
argument pour autant même s'il ne
représente qu'une minorité la volonté
des malades qui veulent devancer la mort
doit être entendu et leur volonté
respectée pourquoi refuser à une
personne la possibilité de choisir de
quel droit lui interdire ce qui pour
elle constitue une délivrance
n'est ce pas là son ultime liberté
lorsqu'une personne souffre au point de
vouloir mettre un terme à une existence
qu'elle juge insupportable
il est important de lui reconnaître ce
droit de lui permettre de ne pas se
suicider dans la clandestinité il ne
s'agit pas d'opposer les soins
palliatifs à l'assistance médicalement
assistée ni de banaliser cette pratique
mais d'accepter au nom de la compassion
au nom de l'humanisme que des personnes
malades puissent rester maîtres de leur
destin je le répète nous ne vont pas
leur enlever cette ultime espace de
liberté déjà voici 35 ans le sénat
examiner une proposition de loi du
sénateur henri caillavet relatives au
droit de vivre sa mort plus de trente
ans après le sujet est toujours
extrêmement douloureux complexe même si
de moins en moins de tabous aussi la
présente proposition de loi et pour
certains d'entre nous imparfaite ou du
moins incomplète
pour autant ce texte a pour objectif de
remettre à la volonté du patient au
coeur des débats
il renforce notamment la place accordée
aux soins palliatifs une nécessité
puisque seuls 20% des personnes qui
devraient en bénéficier ont accès à des
structures
avec en outre madame la ministre et vous
le savez de fortes disparités
territoriales ce que la cour des comptes
a une nouvelle fois dénoncé dans son
dernier rapport annuel
cette situation résulte d'un manque de
moyens et notre collègue barbier l'a
rappelé en discussion générale mais
aussi de l'absence d'une véritable
culture palliative
même si elle a marqué une grande avancée
la loi leonetti de 2005 est encore
aujourd'hui peu connu à la fois par les
patients et le corps médical est mal
appliquée sur tous les personnels
soignants ne sont pas suffisamment
formés à lapproche à l'accompagnement et
au soin des personnes en fin de vie
comme le relevé le rapport 6/4 la
proposition de loi des députés classés
leonetti telle qu'elle a été adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale crée un droit à la
sédation profonde et continue
associé à l'arrêt des traitements
maintient en vie cela signifie que le
patient peut demander à une équipe
médicale sous certaines conditions de
bénéficier d'une sédation jusqu'au
moment du décès cette avancée avait été
saluée par la société française
d'accompagnement et de soins palliatifs
enfin la proposition doit imposer le
respect des directives anticipées au
corps médical ce qui aurait facilité la
décision du médecin et la prise en
charge des personnes incapables
d'exprimer leur volonté mais les
amendements adoptés en séance publique
la semaine dernière ont profondément
modifié le texte jusqu'à le vide et pour
nous de l'essentiel de sa substance
ainsi la sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès a été amputé de la
mention continue jusqu'au décès ce qui
remet en cause le caractère irréversible
du recours à la sédation profonde et ne
créent aucun droit nouveau pour les
patients en fin de vie
par ailleurs les directives anticipées
ne seront plus opposable
c'était pourtant l'une des grandes
avancées de ce texte
pour toutes ces raisons la majorité de
notre groupe regrette que le texte que
nous allons voter dans quelques instants
n'ouvre pas de perspectives nouvelles
aux patients qu'ils réclament pour eux
mêmes
et pour leurs proches une fin de vie
apaisée et digne aussi je les dis la
très grande majorité d'entre nous à
l'exception de notre ami et collègue que
gilbert barbier dans les convictions
sont connus sont respectables et il l'a
exprimé avec tout son honnêteté et sa
conviction au cours des débats a son
exception
nous voterons contre ce texte
avec aussi conviction car nous savons
les uns et les autres qu'il faudra
continuer à avancer
c'est inéluctable c'est conforme à ce
que souhaite la grande majorité de nos
concitoyens et c'est un devoir
d'humanisme je vous remercie monsieur le
président
mes chers collègues il va être procédé
dans les conditions prévues par
l'article 56 de notre règlement au
scrutin public qui sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
ce conformément aux dispositions du
chapitre 15 beast de l'instruction
générale du bureau je rappelle qu'une
seule délégation de vote est admise par
sénateurs je déclare le scrutin ouvert
pour une demi heure et je suspends la
séance